alors darry cowl vous êtes à la fiche
jusqu'au 31 décembre 2002 d'une pièce
qui s'appelle [ __ ] de soirée au
gymnase donc c'est un vaudeville de
daniel nicolas avec patrick chesnais
anémone florence gentil monique tarbes
est et vous voilà alors le pitch je vais
le faire
patrick chesnais est un homme d'affaires
ruiné qui se voit contraint de vendre en
une nuit sans hôtel particulier avant
saisie évidemment tous les acheteurs
sont conviés à dîner pour cette ultime
dîner vous vous êtes le majordome
alcoolo et la soirée vire bien sûr au
cauchemar puisque vous essayer de
l'aider en fait ce n'est pas du tout le
plan qui l'a patrick chesnais voilà vous
[ __ ] le bordel quoi
oui c'est bien j'ai le rôle d'un
majordome et j'assiste à ce set cette
maison qui veulent bonjour ne pas dire
bonjour qu'ils insistent ils insistent
au des gars qui vont se passer durant
toute la soirée
voilà alors voilà et ça n'arrête pas et
moi dieu on me jette du premier étage
trois fois de suite
je suis délabré je dirais contre
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas à pas un grand
sage qu'on y accéder mais c'est puis
voilà et puis ça se termine jeudi pas la
fin parce que ben non ben il faut pas le
dire
voilà ça s'appelle [ __ ] de soirée avec
patrick chesnais anémone et darry cowl
je remercie beaucoup revoir
et vous
pas du tout c'est loin d'être fille
derrière on va voir les deux bouts
d'abord vous appelez pas du tout darry
cowl mais andré darricau oui vous êtes
né en 1925
ouais vous êtes appelés darry cowl parce
que vous étiez dans le jazz ça faisait
america exact voilà un et votre arrière
grand père était un médecin de napoléon
oui c'est exact aussi voilà à bayonne et
votre père est un grand médecin basque
lui aussi d'ailleurs à bas bruit le
problème c'est que vous êtes né d'une
union illégitime
andreu votre père et une fille qui était
venue accoucher chez lui mais qui après
vous abandonnez we dare abandonner ces
mots vous dire et les bourgeois basque
c'est une race très spécial et et oui il
fallait que ça reste secret ouais donc
je connais pas ma mère voilà alors votre
belle-mère pour faire croire que c'était
elle qui avait eu l'enfant elle se
baladait avec avec un petit coussin
gonflable mois en mois comme ça faut que
vous apprenez la vérité à l'âge de 10
ans oui et vous avez malgré tous vos
efforts jamais retrouvé votre mère non
c'est pas grave c'est les façons c'est
pas grave maintenant c'est trop tard
je crois qu'il est parti vous avez
arrêté il complètement de la suivre
alors votre belle mère vous a jamais
vraiment aimé darry cowl parce que votre
père de bord est mort à 8 ans et ça vous
a posé quand même des père est mort il
avait huit ans son père parce que là on
devrait faire un break on lui met une
pile 9 en fumée un club
un canon mais bon ce sont les vases ou
vous avez fumé leur noble ritary je
reviens dans un quart d'heure il en sera
la même question votre mère vous a
jamais aimé d'alcool en plus votre père
était mort quand vous aviez 8 ans et ça
a créé chez vous un certain problème
psychologique j'imagine non non pas du
tout à 17 ans vous faites émancipé pour
épouser une femme de 36 ans donc c'est
bien la preuve comme que vous aviez un
manque mais non ce côté là oui mais ma
mère j'ai j'ai été gentil avec elle
parce que mon père adorait autres vont
jouer il a rien à [ __ ]
oui vous êtes bien occupé d'elle quand
elle était malade à votre belle mère
agitée habitué à fès il imite les j1
donc je passais mon temps à l'hôpital
c'est pas ça qui responsable de votre
fameux bégaiement en fait quand javier 7
8 ans vous aviez fait peur à une vieille
tante dans une église habillé en cow
boys est sorti de derrière un pylône
dans une église de menton s'est fait
voler ma wii et là on vous a pris on
vous a amené à la maison et on vous a
suspendu pendant deux trois minutes au
dessus du vide
oui est bon qu'il y avait déjà du
vertige quand vous mentiez sur une
chaise oui ça vous a complètement
flinguer ça ab oui essayer ici mais les
boutons de mon pantalon pète je vais me
casser la gueule c'est évident ils ont
tenu
ils ont heureusement alors ensuite vous
faites du fait du conservatoire en fait
du cabaret vous êtes accompagnateurs des
plus grands de l'époque de l'époque ils
sont tous mais ils sont partis reda
caire guéthary il ya plus que l'amoureux
qu'elle a dans tout ce que vous avez
accompagné elle même l'amour il ya plus
qu robert lamoureux est alors un jour
justement vous accompagner robert
lamoureux dans les arènes de béziers
il pleut des cordes lamoureux est en
retard
il vous dit fait les patientes et enfin
modifier les patientes et et vous fait
patienter les gens avec une boîte
d'allumettes et vous fait marrer
onze mille personnes avec une boîte
d'allumettes pendant une demi heure
j'adore ces camions mais j'ai été
mouillé parce qu'il pleuvait ouais et je
réclamais mais je peux pas lui mais l'a
lui-même parce qu'il pleuvait c'était le
leitmotiv et j'ai fait une demi heure
avec çà et là les mecs étaient morts de
rire il devenu une star voilà à quoi ça
tient
alors vos sketches et toujours basé sur
des trucs pas drôle au départ un peu sa
compagne et j'accompagne et puis entre
les numéros
au jeu j'ai juge me la vanille se
jettent en démon loges ce public était
ravi
rien de plus que des gouttes sur la tête
oui oui - iliad est ravi de chanter et
c'est là que j'ai connu guitry sacha
guitry favoris puis celle isis il
m'avait donné un film très vite après
assassins et voleurs oui et non ah ouais
grand film voilà après donc qu'il ya le
cabaret des trois baudets qui était un
grand cabaret des années 50 ans 54 dents
vous commencez le cinéma et le théâtre
et vous faites le triporteur qui est un
énorme succès 1,7 c était oui c'était un
grand succès oui énorme moi je me
souviens j'étais à mon bas françois sens
bien aussi un des porteurs des oui non
non il ya cette phrase qui restera
partout c'était au petit canaillou prêts
avait rebondi j'ai sorti s'affirmant
dîner et là malheureusement vous vous
accrochez à une drogue dure
le jeu voilà oh là là ouais j'ai sauvé
et pour payer vos dettes de jeu darry
cowl vous allez faire beaucoup de navets
surtout des navets que des navets disons
bien sûr mais bah oui parce que je
téléphonais la nuit pour mon agent il
faut vider un film et lequel je m'en
fous je vais signer j'ai signé des films
sans les lire a lorsqu'on est le matin
l'après-midi à nos deux films est
souvent le soir un autre film encore
dingue effet plaints ces ingrats oui ça
j'ai vu là je n'avais alors vous allez
planter votre votre carrière 1,15 cette
passion du jeu a duré quand même 15 ans
non oui plus ouais j'ai perdu plus qu'on
ne croit et moins qu'on ne pense et en
plus des deux-tiers d'harry guignard en
plus quoi c'est à dire que
vous gagnez pas souvent qua non qui a eu
la chance d'être malchanceux mais c'est
vrai je
on venait quand j'allais dans un casino
un sac de jeu les gens téléphonaient
venez vite yade eric ok là venez vite il
jouait contre moi il gagnait alors
effectivement le public au départ et
vous adorez et puis comme faisais
n'importe quoi à un moment c'est un peu
comme une maîtresse qu'on délaisse quoi
c'est à dire que finalement tu dis que
ça - exactement
vous devriez donc mais maintenant je
m'efforce d'être d'être plus mieux
élevés en bégayant pas à vous bb n'est
plus du tout la vue un tour et avoir un
c'est bien bon ben on vous félicite on
va vous applaudir
38 km je n'avais pas que le jeu et
l'alcool aussi ça vous étiez capable de
vous envoyer une bouteille de porto
bouteille de scotch comme savoir
pourquoi une wii dizaine voilà c'est dit
c'est incroyable j'ai connu avec
francine blanche j'ai connu l'époque
bière de francis alors c'était la bière
j'ai connu l'époque porto j'ai connu
l'époque vin et j'ai créé maintenant une
petit peu de pastis et tout comme c'est
tout ouais c'est vachement raisonnable à
trets ouais les cigarettes aussi pour 3
j'allumais le matin et j'ai gagné
d'ailleurs j'étais n'y est pas c'est la
nuit ses lauriers l'édredon qui
détaillait vous êtes bien conservé
malgré tout ça c'est incroyable en 17
ans voilà alors vous avez les dos des
tons qu'on connaît pas vous êtes médium
en fait et pendant l'occupation vous
vous rendiez impasse du cardinal mercier
à clichy chez eux chez deux anglaises
arrêts et elle ce service vous pour
entrer en contact avec l'au delà
en transe rigide voilà entrés en transe
et vous vous en faites me souvenais de
rien quoi vous présentez sérieux c est
très sérieux et que j'avais des médecins
il prenait ma tension il me réveillait
12 m'en vais me réveiller
il mettait de la transe avec précaution
le docteur guerni qui s'occupait de vous
à ce moment là qu l'an dernier claude
garnier comment il sait ça fait c'est
vrai et alors quand vous sortiez de live
vous donnez votre argent quand vous
sortiez de là et vous baladiez dans la
rue malgré malgré le couvre-feu imposé
devant nos souhaits et s'en régaler en
langue via nice mais vous dites les
allemands ne m'approchais pas card ma
silhouette était auréolé de mots c'était
aux eti complètement électrique après
les serveurs et les 100 g t or et c'est
bizarre gt oui c'est vrai
j'étais complètement électrique quoi
vous aviez le sentiment d' éclairer les
gens
ah oui oui c'était dingue ouais mais si
une époque que je serais devenu fou on
avoue vous avez arrêté là et alors après
dans les années 50
vous avez vu des soucoupes volantes
aussi we had c'est vrai ça je suivrai
l'histoire des scoops voulons bien sûr
vierge il vit ça il ya entendu c'était
entre nice et cassis vous ameniez la
chanteuse accepte les souris sourit
qu'elle est avec sa mère sa mort mais à
un moment dans un tournant vous voyez
une soucoupe volante
oui mais riez pas c'est vrai
moi je sais que c'est vrai d'harry
laisser les rires moi je sais que vous
étiez dans une traction je me souviens
très bien
c'est la mère de souris quand elle a du
sel a failli tomber dans les pommes mais
bon voilà faillir est tombé dans la
balance et moi j'étais tout content
voilà je crois pas aux petits bonshommes
verts mais je m'en aux objets comme ça
qui circulent on va on va dans les dix
ans où on lira à 20 km de saturne et de
mars
je vois pas pourquoi il y aurait pas
d'autres y a pas que nous bien sûr mais
aussi beaucoup bien sûr surtout surtout
faut bien dire que vous avez revu
quand vous étiez en chine avec belmondo
vous avez revu des soucoupes volantes
oui mais sachez pas sûr
deux premières fois c'est sûr j ai bavé
des ronds s'est passé presque serrer la
main
un arrêt d'âge était tout prêt oui pis
c'est parti c'est parti comme ça oui oui
comme le souk torrent comme les
soucoupes volantes d'ailleurs